Thomas Verrette, Director, Producer,
Editor: That was the biggest break for
me that I had in a way for my
own career just to be like I’m
producing a series that's going to go
to TV that's never been done before.
Film Courage:
How did you go from an independent filmmaker
to Fox creative and production executive?
Thomas: That story starts on Craigslist.
Actually when I first moved to Los Angeles
I was applying for lots of jobs and didn't
know anybody. A lot of those jobs I would
apply for on Craigslist and one of
them was actually for an editor at Fox
but it didn't say where it was from. That
was a surprise to me when they wrote back.
Anyway I ended up working for them as an editor
for four years I think and that was when I was
talking earlier about how I worked as an editor
and but then I also was like who's doing the post
and managing all that and then I sort of was like
I'm going to do it and nobody ever told me not to
and I you know once I did it once and it turned
out great we hit our deliveries and everything
came out on budget and it looked great for
you know very little money let's say we would
do it again and do it again and do it again
and about that went on for about four years
on and off of course and I then I went into
my my euro backpacking trip because I was like
you know like I said I was working like just
too much I needed a break and when I got back
I took a job for directv and cutting promos and
producing and directing some of them as well
which then was bought by att and around that
time my former boss at fox that you did a lot
of editorial for he was he basically took me to
dinner one day and was like hey I think I have an
opportunity for you if if you'd be interested
he had known about my travels and things like
that and and was also a huge soccer fan
and then he kind of basically presented
the project phenoms and that was how I got
involved there doing as a production executive
and really it was mostly post-production
as well because we had to design and create
an entire infrastructure for something that
hadn't really been done I mean that series was
shot in 20 countries for almost three years
and it was up to me basically to figure out
how to manage the post-production for that
entire project that had it was a 20 episode
series but five of them were in the u.s and 15
international episodes also and coordinating with
all the production teams internationally and
it was just a massive project and I i like to
think that I did a good enough job on those on the
projects that I had worked with him on previously
where I sort of took over the post-production on
things that I was just editing is what sort of
gave him the faith in my ability to be able to
handle that and it was very stressful because I
had never done something like that big before but
I also you know had a great team and was able to
collaborate and work together with a bunch of
other producers to make all that stuff happen so
but that opportunity came about because of
a relationship and doing a good job I like
to think previously and so when he asked you
to be a part of it was there something in you
later on that night that said oh why'd I
say yes to this because you said it would
seem stressful but no no it was more like
holy mole. I mean excuse my French but like
because you know it wasn't like I just started
the next day I mean there was a process to get
like everything up and running and and it didn't
just happen overnight but it was definitely an
opportunity that I like absolutely couldn't say
no to I mean that was it was you know that that
series was broadcast on fox and fox sports and
in like many many international markets as well
that was the biggest like break for me that i'd
had in a way for my own career just to be like I'm
producing a series that's going to go to TV
that's never been done before and it also made
the editorial very difficult because it was
also my first time really doing documentaries
and you know you don't have script but you
still have air dates and you still got to
back into those air dates and make episodes that
have stories to create and with all that material
from all over the world it was just a very
big project but I also didn't want to to just
you know manage the post-production I also
really was like this this thing is super cool
like I loved it so I wanted to edit an episode
and so that was part of partially why it was
as stressful as it was for me because I was
handling a lot at once and I didn't maybe maybe
stupidly I i just was like I need to play with
the creative of this way more in the weeds than I
like than anybody asked me to do nobody asked
me to do that that was that was for me like if
I'm going to put this all together and really
make all these pieces happen and I got to get
in there a little bit too and so so that was
maybe something that I won't never do again
just because it was way too demanding but I'm glad
I did it also once you know it's it's one of those
I think I had the stamina at the time to handle
it but I i don't think I could do it again like
that exactly it was really intense like running
with the bulls yeah it was like that it was very
different but like but I but it definitely felt at
times like the whole thing you know I don't know
I mean like there's so many pieces to that puzzle
that that if in post-production that like always
gets affected and so and but you still like it so
it was my responsibility to to get those episodes
to air on time so yeah like needless to say to me
I was like this is my personal responsibility and
if I mess up I'm doomed forever you know I
mean that's how I kind of thought about it and
but again it's like I wasn't alone I had
many many really talented editors and
and other producers and helping make all
this stuff happen and so it wasn't like
all on me but I still put that pressure on
myself you know I'm saying that's maybe just
something that I just do innately because I
I'm like protective and and my like heart and
is in the project and that's you know when I
said before like I can get sometimes obsessive
about stuff that's part of what I mean is like
I'm like this is this is the biggest thing i've
ever done no I you know it's the only thing it
matters and that you have to talk yourself back
from that a little bit and be like no we're not
curing cancer but it still doesn't matter and it's
still very important so it's just a balance that
I learned a lot from doing that and what I do and
don't want to do again going forward but it was an
amazing opportunity and I'm really glad that that
I had it actually so when you flew back from St.
Petersburg Russia you went to go see the game yeah
I went so yeah after after I delivered all those
episodes I went to to Russia for the World Cup for
two or three weeks basically I went
to I went to St. Petersburg in Moscow
and we also had a production team shooting during
those years for for the series so I also got to
you know meet I mean it was a really fantastic
way to kind of cap that three-year journey
what was the flight like back home I was
kind of ready to be home by that point
but I have to say that anytime I come back from a
vacation especially one that's international I do
have like a little period of like depression
that I have to like get out of it's it's it
happens every time honestly it's just something
I'm like used to now it's like yo you had this
amazing experience but then like you know you
need to kind of rest but you don't want to
but you don't know what you're doing now it's
like very like that little just uncertainty period
after you get back and you're like what did it
all mean and you know it's part of of how I have
to handle it myself I don't know if that's the
same for everybody but definitely happens to me
can you explain more about the work that you
did on phenoms so as I mentioned we that series
was shot in 20 countries and we
basically were following 65 of the young
up and coming stars who are trying to make their
national teams for the World Cup in Russia and
so we had I think six maybe eight production teams
internationally shooting with all those players
and then in Los Angeles we had our
basically a global series kind of team
which included my entire office and eventually I
think at one point we may have had like 30 editors
on this project including assistant editors and
and then an entire archive team for licensing the
material that we were using as editors it was a
long road though because we didn't actually start
like the real production on what the series would
become at the be like it didn't just start that
way a lot of it was you know as a documentary
you're you're sort of like the story has to
kind of unfold in front of you I mean we had a
a guide by utilizing the World Cup and and sort
of what the goal was but those players had to
tell your tell their stories they had to either
succeed or fail and then those things would
have to be captured on camera or at least in
interviews for us to all find how how best to
tell those parts of the of their stories and
keep in mind there's also language barriers and
or many languages not barriers but many languages
that were also editing in so putting that all
together was a road of I mean some of it was
designed some of it was exploratory basically and
it was about six months before we were the the
show was to air and that was really where we began
the episodic nature of the series we basically
were just kind of cutting material for a year
up to that point just refining it down like
so you know eight terabytes would come in from
Russia and France and so and then that would go
get subtitled when necessary and then logged by
the AES and then sent over to the editorial team
which ended up expanding into another office
because we ran out of space and then we had to
also kind of keep in mind that all that material
had to go from each location and all be always be
synced it's a lot a lot of technical stuff that
I'm not sure how much that is really valuable to
this audience but it was definitely complicated
it's very technical but at the end of the day
it was really just about finding the story
that was that was the pursuit and the best way
that we found to do that was to be edit editing
constantly even if we didn't know it was going to
be part of the episode or not because we had to
figure out what was in the material first and
so it was kind of like draft one you could say
like a script where it's just your it's your vomit
draft it's kind of if you think about it that way
and then the episodes happened and
we also had ancillary content that
was getting created for Fox sports out of
all that material as well as deliveries
and then I was also editing an episode as well
I edited The Goalkeepers episode of the series
and which I'm you know still is one of my
favorite things i've ever done honestly
it's I'm i'm really proud of of how it turned
out and I didn't actually get a whole lot of
notes and things like that like like I felt
like I had like sort of cracked something
and to the point where like you know I
kind of got left alone a little bit more
than I was used to which was excellent for me
but also kind of like well what do you think
about this like come on guys tell me like you know
I mean there were so many other things to go like
going on at the time that were you know logistic
you know like my post coordinator like did a
fantastic job I mean like a lot of those people
that came in really really brought everything
together to make that show happen I mean it
doesn't happen it was such a post-heavy project
too that I'm you know I'm very glad that that my
boss at the time you know trusted me to do it but
if I could if if you had asked me in the beginning
did I would did I would I have known that that
we were going to be able to pull it off I
wouldn't have been able to tell you honestly
but I would have said yes because why not I mean
like we have to figure it out together and that's
part of the part of the process so it's also
money related and so many other things too
well and you had these air date deadlines that
you were fighting against too yes yeah we knew
exactly when they were going to air probably like
six months out I think which was basically the
the the first the three Fridays leading up to the
World Cup the one thing that really that really
hurt that series at least in my opinion was
the fact that the us didn't make the World Cup
and that was just something that none of us could
have like expected I mean I i think that it was
like 12 years before since the the us hadn't
made the the World Cup by that point so it was
a big surprise to all of us and really kind of I
remember that there was probably like a two-week
period in there where we were really like a little
worried about what that meant for the series at
least in the us I guess that that episode though
that covers the US disqualification is fantastic
it was cut by a good friend of mine and
it's devastating to watch like because
it was so much a part of at least our culture
I don't know about the entire country because
I think it was like you know it wasn't as big of
a deal as if we were in it of course but but I'm
a huge fan of the game and so it was very much a
big like passion project for me that I had a lot
of people that were also like huge fans involved
in the project I mean that's the only reason
I even got made is because people love that game
and sorry why was the US disqualified oh they just
didn't win they didn't they didn't make it they
didn't they didn't they didn't qualify for the
World Cup I see it okay so they were disqualified
in that sense so there was no scandal it was just
that no no yeah they just they just didn't play
well enough and so it was a devastating result.
What did this video teach you?